salut les épicurieuses et les épicurieux
je ne sais pas où vous êtes en ce moment
peut-être en vacances sur le point de
partir ou de rentrer peut-être
faites-vous partie de celles et ceux qui
ne reviennent jamais les mains vides un
petit souvenir qui troncera quelque part
chez vous je me suis dit que c'était une
bonne occasion de vous raconter
l'histoire de certains objets qui
décorent mon atelier que j'ai rapporté
pour la plupart de vacances ou de voyage
on commence par ce drôle de caillou
je vous en ai déjà parlé sur la chaîne
epicurieux je l'ai ramassé sur les
pentes de l'Etna en Sicile c'était pour
un tournage de l'émission C'est pas
sorcier après une nuit à la fois
extraordinaire et infernal pendant
laquelle j'ai assisté en direct à ma
première éruption volcanique je pourrais
vous en parler pendant des heures tout a
commencé aux alentours de minuit on
avait été prévenus par les volcanologues
qui m'avait précisé de nous étions à 500
mètres du cratère que le cratère
lui-même faisait 500 mètres de hauteur
et que la fontaine de la au moment de ce
qu'on appelle paroxysme de l'éruption
mesurait elle aussi 500 mètres de
hauteur je vous promets que à ce stade
et bien on sentait la chaleur de la lave
on sentait également une petite odeur de
soufre petit matin on est rentré sur
Catane la ville la plus proche où nous
étions basés une partie de l'équipe dont
j'étais a fait un bout de chemin à pied
et c'est là sur
les pentes de l'Etna que j'ai ramassées
ce drôle de caillou on appelle ça une
bombe en fait il s'agit d'un lambeau de
lave projeté en l'air qui en retombant
parce qu'il était liquide a pris la
forme d'une goutte
quand on le soupe c'est très dense et ça
se voit très bien
quand on regarde à l'intérieur parce que
le même jour j'ai ramassé celle-ci
celle-ci qui s'est fracassée en fait
cette bombe s'est brisée en deux quand
elle a touché le sol et on va très très
bien l'intérieur on voit que c'est très
très dense en fait c'est du basalte le
même basalte que l'on utilise sur les
routes ou sur les voies de chemin de fer
et puis on voit aussi qu'il y a des
petits trous à la surface comme des
petits cratères bien ça c'est la trace
du dégazage quand le Lambo de lave s'est
retrouvé en l'air il était plein de gaz
et ce gaz est remonter à la surface et
en sortant et bien il a laissé ses
marques
j'ai acheté ce mug au Canada à bord du
pierres Radisson un bateau ce bateau il
s'agit d'un brise-glace qui libère
navigue sur le fleuve Saint-Laurent
nous avions embarqué dans le cadre d'un
numéro du monde de Jamy consacré au
froid extrême le Saint-Laurent et le
cordon ombilical du Québec et navires
marchand l'empreinte pour alimenter une
partie du pays le passage doit donc
rester libre en permanence keranisme
donc le fleuve est décla glace se forme
il accourt et brise d'énormes morceaux
de banquise pour libérer le passage de
jour comme de nuit il y a même un
hélicoptère à bord qui patrouille pour
repérer d'éventuelles obstacles alors
j'en profite évidemment pour vous
expliquer comment fonctionne un
brise-lass contrairement à une idée
reçue ce n'est pas la collision frontale
du bateau avec la glace qui brise la
glace la coque à l'avant du navire est
recourbé vers l'extérieur le bulbe a une
forme convexe qui permet au bateau de
grimper sur la banquise et c'est le
poids du bateau qui brise la glace
plutôt doit donc mettre les gaz pour
profiter de soninerci et en même temps
se dégager très rapidement pour ne pas à
son tour être pris par la glace c'est
très impressionnant surtout le bruit
j'entendez c'est le bruit de la glace
qui se brise je suis d'abord du pierre
Radisson un brise-glace qui sillonne le
Saint-Laurent durant tout l'hiver c'est
sur ce bateau que j'ai tourné ces images
qui sont devenues un gif
le bruit quand je regarde ce mug je
repense bien sûr assez long moment passé
sur le pont malgré le froid c'est pour
cette raison d'ailleurs que c'est un mug
hermos
voici une plaque émaillée en forme de
triangle ce qui signifie attention
danger avec un ours polaire à
l'intérieur alors bien sûr il s'agit
d'un fac similaire mais c'est la
reproduction d'un panneau de
signalisation que l'on croise à tous les
coins de rue à longueur bide c'est le
nom la capitale de l'archipel bus
valbard située ici dans le cercle
polaire
78 degrés de latitude nord pour info le
Pôle Nord se trouve à 90 degrés logique
la terre étant une affaire en partant de
l'équateur l'attitude 0 on parcourt 90
degrés pour atteindre le pôle Nord le
cercle polaire lui est une ligne
imaginaire au-delà de laquelle pendant
une période il fait jour ou nuit suivant
la saison 24 heures sur 24 et plus on se
rapproche du pôle plus cette période est
longue 78 degrés de latitude nord c'est
pas très loin du Pôle Nord et jamais je
ne suis monté si haut quand je suis allé
c'était début mai il a fait durant tout
le voyage je vous promets que ça fait
très bizarre d'ouvrir les yeux à deux
heures du matin alors qu'il fait grand
jour comme en pleine après-midi mais
revenons à la première plaque celle avec
l'ours alors effectivement cet animal
est présent sur l'archipel y compris
dans les rues de longueur bin où ils
s'aventure régulièrement pour chercher
de la nourriture c'est un animal très
dangereux on pense là-bas les habitants
se promènent avec une carabine en
bandoulière j'ai même vu des étudiants
rentrer de l'université avec une
carabine sur l'épaule je vous promets ça
surprend alors la question que vous
posez maintenant c'est est-ce que j'ai
vu l'ours d'abord je dois préciser le
contexte dans lequel je suis allé là-bas
c'était il y a quelques années dans le
cadre d'un épisode du monde de Jamy
consacré à la cohabitation homme animal
sauvage pour observer l'ours dans son
milieu naturel nous nous sommes écartés
de la ville une journée de motoneige
tenez là c'est moi bon je sais on a un
peu de mal à me reconnaître sous la
combinaison et mais c'est bien moi et là
c'est la cabane de trappeur dans
laquelle nous logions avec l'équipe nous
étions accompagnés par deux guides un
français spécialiste de ce genre de
milieu Nicolas Dubreuil et un guide
norvégien qui lui est éterné maintenant
ma première rencontre avec l'ours nous
étions donc arrivé à destination et en
discutant pendant le repas le trappeur
qui nous hébergeait nous informe qu'il
avait vu des traces le matin même de
l'autre côté du fjord du coup aux
environs de 23h alors qu'il faisait
évidemment grand jour nous décidons de
sortir les caméras et de nous équiper
bah oui il faut quand même rappeler
quelque chose aux alentours de moins 20
degrés et que avec la vitesse des
motoneiges la sensation c'est plutôt de
l'ordre de -40 nous en fourchons donc
les motoneiges
et nous décidons d'aller tenter notre
chance alors après environ une
demi-heure de trajet nous repérons les
premières traces il faut dire qu'elles
sont assez faciles à repérer quand la
neige est immaculée dans mes souvenirs
ensuite nous n'avons pas eu à chercher
trop longtemps mais ce n'est pas l'ours
que nous avons d'abord vu aux jumelles
mais sa proie un phoque immobile sur le
sol précédé d'une longue trace rouge
nous descendons des motoneiges et nous
approchons nous sommes 5 il y a deux
cadreurs de guides d'autres armés et moi
on constate que le sang est encore frais
le terrain est très vallonné le guide
norvégien propose alors à Stéphane le
réalisateur de faire le tour du
monticule l'ours est sûrement de l'autre
côté
avec Nicolas Dubreuil et Richard notre
cadreur nous avons souvent un peu puis
nous nous arrêtons et nous nous
allongeons dans la neige en silence nous
sommes à environ une trentaine de mètres
de la proie le camarade on disparu
derrière la colline on attend
et puis d'un seul coup surgit devant
nous pile dans l'axe du phoque l'ours
à ce moment là il est à une cinquantaine
de mètres de nous alors il y a une autre
arme mais elle est restée dans le coffre
une motoneige qui se trouve à une
centaine de mètres trop long nous ne
bougeons pas l'ours je m'en souviens il
nous regarde on ne filme pas non plus
l'objectif de la caméra pourrait le
stresser l'animal et là
alors Nicolas est quelqu'un de très
grand à haut à basse il nous dit à mon
top on se lève on agite les bras et on
hurle de toutes nos forces message reçu
l'ours
s'avance vers nous vous savez de sa
démarche très assurée
on attend le signal quand l'ours arrive
au niveau de la proie
il s'immobilise
il se trouve maintenant à une trentaine
de mètres en quelques secondes il peut
être sur nous on ne bouge plus
lentement
qu'il saisit sa proie puis fait
demi-tour et disparaît derrière le
monticule de neige
Nathan encore un peu puis le calme se
fait dans nos têtes et je vous promets
qu'à ce moment-là le sang cesse de
frapper dans mes tempes et je pousse un
grand ouf de soulagement cette nuit là
croyez-moi
j'ai très bien dormi
nous n'avons fait aucune image de cette
rencontre les images elles sont dans nos
têtes quelques jours plus tard nous
avons recroisé un ours cette fois nous
avions pris toutes nos précautions une
fois encore l'ours s'est approché très
près de nous nous avons filmé et là j'ai
pu prendre quelques photos
[Musique]
je vous propose maintenant un peu de
chaleur autour du feu ou plutôt autour
d'un kit pour lancer un feu comme le
faisait nos ancêtres au Néolithique on
me l'a offert pour le tournage une vidéo
spéciale classe grandeur nature
consacrée aux gorges de l'Ardèche le
lien est ici une très belle expérience
dans un lieu exceptionnel la cité de la
préhistoire de pas de la veine d'Orgnac
on est du coup le mode de vie de nos
ancêtres en contemplant des
reconstitutions et en reproduisant des
gestes vieux de 10000 ans alors de quoi
est-il constitué à l'intérieur on trouve
deux pierres du silex et de la marque
acide la marque acide contient beaucoup
de fer en percutant l'une contre l'autre
on produit des étincelles pour faire du
feu il faut aussi de l'amadou
c'est très très doux en fait c'est un
champignon l'amadouvier il pousse sur
les troncs d'arbres en tombant les
étincelles mettent le feu à l'amadou qui
se consume assez lentement en posant
ensuite les braises dans un coquillage
quelques brindilles on souffle un peu et
on obtient de belles flammes j'avoue que
le geste pour produire des étincelles
est assez technique l'autre méthode
consiste à utiliser un support en bois
comme celui-ci dans lequel on a pratiqué
au préalable des encoches un bois assez
tendre du pain ou du sapin il faut aussi
une tige rigide taillée dans un bois un
peu plus dur et un objet
comme celui-ci attention ce n'est pas un
arc on coince la tige dans la lanière
puis on place la pointe de la tige à
côté d'une encoche on la tient bien à la
verticale en appuyant au sommet en ces
noms d'une coquille puis on utilise
l'arc comme un archer la tige entre en
rotation et creuse la planche petit
copeau fantasme au niveau de l'encoche
la rotation génère de la chaleur qui met
le feu à la sûr la récupère qui
Saint-Jacques brindille souffle et le
tour est joué
[Musique]
alors après la visite du musée cette
expérience surtout ne manquez pas la
découverte de la veine d'Orgnac je n'ai
pas de mots pour décrire cette grotte
c'est un festival de stalagmit et de
stalactite les concrétions prennent des
formes invraisemblables c'est vraiment
très très beau inoubliable l'un des plus
beaux spectacles souterrains que la
nature est produite voilà j'espère que
vous avez passé un bon moment tous ces
objets sont merveilleux bien sûr mais
les meilleurs souvenirs sont des images
que nous gardons en mémoire de nos
vacances d'ailleurs je me disais ce
serait peut-être bien pour l'été
prochain une petite série autour des
souvenirs de vacances avec des têtes
connues de YouTube ou d'ailleurs quand
pensez-vous j'attends vos commentaires
et je vous dis
à très bientôt
[Musique]